-Dinner is ready.
-Why didn't you ask me if I was hungry?  -I did.
You said you'd be hungry by 6. It's 6:30 now.
-But I am not,
so I don't want it now.
-How's work?
-Fine!
-Is something wrong? -No, I'm fine. Just stop asking me.
-Babe, you don't wanna have it, then just don't have it. You don't have to eat it.
-I'm sorry but you've got this thing in your head about like,
'ooh I'm gonna make a really authentic Italian dinner', and it's just this absolutely rank, raw.. -That's al dente.
-That's al dente?
Alright, sorry my mistake.
It's lovely.
Mmm, delicious
Right, come on.
Oh for God's sake. -Leave me alone.
-Now come on get dressed we're gonna be late. Come on.
-I'm not going. -What? you have to come, it's not just any old dinner it's my mom's birthday.
She's expecting you to be there.
-No, I don't even like your mom I don't know why you keep asking me to go to these things.
-You don't have to come. I'll tell them you're not well,
and try and leave early and come back and we'll just watch a film or something.
-Stop, stop it, stop. -What's wrong?
-I said stop! I am reading.
I am reading a book, you never give me any space!
-Sorry. I don't mean to crowd to you. It's fine, no pressure.
-No, I'm sorry, I didn't mean to explode like that.
-It's okay.
I love you.
-I love you too, but I am gonna read.
Ah! Oh God, it's as scary as it looks. Scary book. [Girl laughing]
-That's the part that guy told you.
-Oh!